Let us first see what the problem
is with cache coherence,
that is do we even need cache coherence.
Our programmer is expecting to
see shared memory behavior.
That means that when one core writes,
let's say, 15 to a variable.
And then another core
reads that variable.
It will read what
the last write put there.
This is how cores communicate
through shared memory.
One writes something to
a shared memory address.
Another one reads it and expects to
see the data that was written there.
But in our hardware,
each core has its own cache.
And we need cores to have their own
caches at least into level one because
a single large level one cache would
be too slow and would not have enough
throughput to keep up with
the requests from all of the cores.
So because we cannot do this,
we have private or per-core L1 caches.
So each core has it's own.
However, once you have this private
caches, here is what can happen.
This is the core A with
the level 1 cache for core A.
This is core B and
it has its own level 1 cache.
So we said that let's say
core A writes x equals 15.
Suppose this a cache miss, we use the
address effects to index into our cache.
Check the tag whether
it corresponds to x.
And then, if this is a cache miss,
we go to our main memory and
fetch the whole block into our cache.
Let's say that in this block x is 0.
Once we fetch it into our cache,
we'll write our 15 here.
So now we have a 15 in our cache here.
Now let's say that
core B wants to read x.
So it wants to see what x is.
It uses the address of x to
index into its own cache.
Sees that it doesn't have
what it's looking for there.
And reads the block from main memory.
This block here has 0 for
X still because we didn't
write back from A's cache yet.
So, we end up reading 0,
which is not correct.
And know that this doesn't
occur only the first time
when we have a cache miss.
>From now on, A can write to its
own L1 cache many, many times.
B can read from its own cache many,
many times.
A will keep writing to its cache and
not updating memory.
B will keep reading from its cache and
not checking back
from memory because once we bring it
into the cache, it's going to be a hit.
B is never modifying it.
It's always going to read 0 no
matter how many times A writes 15 or
something else here.
So obviously we are not getting
the communication of data we want from
A's writes to B's reads.
And thus our shared memory doesn't work.
When we get in a shared memory system
behavior like this we say that it is
incoherent.
The same memory location as
seen from different cores
can have different values.
Which is not what should be
happening in a shared memory.
In order to not get a incoherent system,
we need an active approach
to cache coherence that will make this
whole thing behave as a single memory.
Even though in reality there
are multiple copies of the data floating
around.